There are many qualities necessary in order to be a professional musician,...
...not the least of which are passion and determination,...
...which can manifest themselves in many different ways.
It must be remembered that there are invariably numerous people...
...vying for the same, often underpaid work or opportunities.
And there will inevitably be disappointment along the road to success.
Music gives much fulfillment and pleasure, but should not be regarded as an easy option.
A strong conviction in what one is doing and self-belief...
...are indispensable tools of the professional musician.
However, one also has to be realistic.
And it would be kinder to oneself not to embark on this career path...
...unless you're totally sure that this is what you want to do.
Seek advice from as many people in the profession as is reasonably possible.
And consider consultation lessons from a range of teachers.